herzlich willkommen zur folge 191 das
rezept einspruch podcast das
wöchentlichen podcast der faz für recht
justiz und politik heute zwei tage vor
weihnachten am 22 dezember 2021 mein
name ist corinna budras und mit dabei
ist außerdem piano ransmayr heute haben
wir mal was ganz besonderes vor ein
richtige spezial hatten wir lange schon
nicht mehr und auf diese folge habe ich
mich besonders gefreut weil sie uns die
gelegenheit gibt dinge geradezurücken
und heikle themen noch einmal zu
vertiefen und da ja vielleicht vor
weihnachten auch eine ganz schöner
anlass eine ganz schöne gelegenheit dies
zu tun wer sich erinnert in folge 182
haben wir den justiz rummel um den
drachen dort schon einmal angerissen und
es so ein bisschen als kuriosum abgetan
ist und wie eine schlimme sache völlig
abgedreht aber mal weiter im text und
dann wurde dieser drachen ort genannt
auch rainer w also im richtigen leben
heißt rainer w er wurde zu zwei jahren
haft verurteilt und auch das haben wir
berichtet rainer w ist verurteilt worden
wegen gefährlicher körperverletzung und
beleidigung von sogenannten eltern das
sind menschen die ihm bei youtube folgen
seinem kanal in dem er sehr häufig dinge
sendet und die anti fans sind quasi
diese menschen schlagen seit jahren auf
bei ihm vor dem haus in bayern und
belästigen ihn dort und rainer w ist
jetzt schon mehrfach dadurch aufgefallen
und auch schon verurteilt worden weil er
körperlich ausfällig geworden ist weil
er sich gewehrt haben so könnte man
seiner sicht so sieht zumindest er dass
sich gewehrt hat gegen diese menschen
und weil er außerdem polizistinnen und
polizisten beleidigt hat die seiner
meinung nach nicht häufig genug und
nicht schnell genug auf schlagen wenn er
mal wieder um hilfe genau das ist der
sachverhalt wie er sich uns dargestellt
hat als wir darüber sprachen und dann
haben wir uns noch mal ein bisschen
vertieft er damit beschäftigt nachdem
sascha lobo eine kolumne veröffentlicht
hat auf spiegel online die unter dem
titel erschien ein jahrelanges martyrium
in deutschland und niemand hält es auf
und im vorspann der youtuber drachen
nord wird seit jahren von einem mob
gequält bedroht und belästigt nun hat er
sich gewehrt und wurde zu einer
haftstrafe verurteilt ein katastrophales
versagen von justiz medien und
gesellschaft
und dazu haben wir uns zwei menschen
herbei geholt die sich mit dem thema
mehr oder weniger lange und mehr oder
weniger intensiv beschäftigen zum
teilweise ist müssen zum teil weil sie
es wollen und wir freuen uns heute sehr
über ulrike löw die kollegin löw ist
rechts reporterin bei den nürnberger
nachrichten und verfolgt dass das oder
die verfahren rund um den so genannten
drachen lord schon seit jahren hallo
frau luftballon stellen konnte und
unser zweiter gast ist friedrich weiter
herr weidner ist nicht nur richter am
oberlandesgericht in nürnberg wo die
verhandlung stattgefunden hat gegen den
sogenannten drachen lord sondern er ist
auch leiter der dortigen
justizpressestelle und daher sehr sehr
gut vertraut mit dem gesamten verfahren
das ja auch für extrem medialen wirbel
gesorgt hat
hallo frau beatrice hallo frau lorenz
ich freue mich dass ich mich zu diesem
gespräch eingeladen haben
ja und das ist in der tat wird ein
gespräch das keine grenzen kennt wir
wollen uns da sowohl zeitlich als auch
inhaltlich wir wollen uns damit intensiv
auseinandersetzen weil vielleicht auch
dieser ganze fall drachen ort ja auch
vielleicht für etwas steht für etwas was
wir schon seit jahren beobachten im netz
nämlich cybermobbing und das war es was
dann im realen leben daraus wird und wie
das die justiz beschäftigt vielleicht
mal ein kleiner disclaimer vorweg ich
glaube nicht dass wir abschließend
klären können ob justiz medien und
gesellschaft kollektiv versagt haben so
wie es sascha lobo formuliert hat es
bedürfte doch dann vielleicht eines
größeren aufwand ist aber wir wollen
noch mal die frage aufwerfen also hat
die justiz haben die medien tatsächlich
versagt im fall drachen lord und wie
geht die justiz generell mit mobbing
opfern um was kann sie leisten was muss
sie gezwungenermaßen links liegen lassen
weil das strafrecht für eine
aufarbeitung schlicht nicht gemacht ist
und hier kann man eben noch mal sagen
jetzt liegt auch das schriftliche urteil
vor das haben wir uns natürlich die
vorgeknöpft vor der sendung sind 30
seiten die auch vielleicht noch mal sehr
klar darlegen welche überlegungen sich
das gericht eigentlich gemacht hat und
jetzt wollen wir doch vielleicht gleich
mal einsteigen und hören von ihnen
frauen vielleicht führen sie uns mal ein
sie haben ja wirklich auch diese ganze
saga die ganze drachen ort sager sich
schon länger angeguckt vielleicht
erzählen sie erstmal was ist denn rainer
w punkt für ein mensch wo sind sie ihm
zum ersten mal begegnet
ja also ich bin dem rainer w tatsächlich
zum ersten mal hier zufällig begegnet
als ich überhaupt nicht wusste dass es
den sogenannten drachen lohr zu nehmen
dass sich selbst als kunstfigur
überhaupt gibt und zwar war das ein
strafverfahren eine hauptverhandlung am
landgericht nürnberg fürth im jahre
2016 unterstand vor gericht ein gewisser
alexander s der hat auch eine gewisse
popularität erlangt weil er der erste
sogenannte deutsche sorting täter
verurteilt ist sporting das weiß
natürlich wahrscheinlich jetzt auch kein
mensch was das ist sporting ist ein
phänomen es kommt aus den usa und
bezieht sich dem board nach auf die swot
einheiten also die polizisten und
feuerwehrleute sieht es im fernsehen bei
so action serien wenn die größere
einsätze haben und bomben entschärfen
müssen und dann zu militärisch fast
gekleidet sind jedenfalls immer sehr
martialisch auftretende sind die swat
teams und wenn man dir also zu unrecht
ruft als missbrauch von notrufen quasi
dann nennt sich dieses phänomen sporting
und der deutschlandweit erste doping
fall ging also auf das konto dieses
alexander s
angeklagt worden war und da waren sie
als gerichtsreporterin unterwegs und
haben wir genauer hingeguckt genau da
war ich als gerichtsreporterin unterwegs
und wollte eben tatsächlich über dieses
phänomen berichten und als zeugin ist
dann der drachen lord also reiner sie
geladen gewesen zu dem zeitpunkt wusste
ich nicht wer das sein soll es hat sich
dann im laufe des verfahrens allerdings
geklärt dass dieser zeuge rainer wie
eben möglich promi im netz ist und er
hatte zu dem damaligen zeitpunkt schon
33.000 etwa abonnenten bei youtube und
hat eben seine finchen produziert er
wurde zum opfer von diesen cyberone
diesem alexander s der auf seinen namen
also man kennt es das phänomen dass
menschen pizzen für andere bestellen um
die zu ärgern aber in jedem fall gegen
das also richtig weit er hat auf die
adresse von dem rainer w
kinderpornografie geladen hat
materialien zum bombenbau bestellt und
an den rainer w liefern lassen und daher
darauf mal die feuerwehr angerufen und
die polizei angerufen behauptet das haus
von dem reinery würde brennen also ein
riesenspektakel
ständig eben auf kosten des rainer w und
man sieht schon an der art der
bestellung wie perfide dass es natürlich
hat der beabsichtigt gehabt dass der
rainer w als mutmaßliche bombenbauer
oder als mutmaßlicher verbreiter von
kinderpornografie selber großen ärger
bekommt und wie sich das also der
rheiner wohnen im sehr kleinen dorf hat
sich
seelenleben da und was kann man sich
vorstellen was da los ist wenn da
plötzlich 25 feuerwehrleute
streifenwägen
rettungswagen also der ganze bahnhof
steht plötzlich vor dem sei höher weil
behauptet wird das haus würde brennen da
sieht man schon ganz deutlich sie haben
ihn als opfer tatsächlich kennen gelernt
gesehen wie hat auf sie gewirkt als er
im gerichtssaal saß und also berichten
musste was ihm widerfährt
also ich beschreibe ihn mal äußerlich
nicht weil ich ihn diskriminieren möchte
ist sondern weil es in seinem fall
sicher eine rolle spielt wie ihr
auftritt und wie er aussieht
damit er oder
damit er sozusagen zum opfer überhaupt
werden konnte er ist heute 32 jahre alt
als er damals mitte 20 ist
schwergewichtig auffällig
schwergewichtig
seine schulbildung ist nicht besonders
weitreichend dass er eine förderschule
besucht er hat keinen abschluss er ist
allerdings um mit da kein
missverständnis aufkommt kein mensch der
auffällig
anständig wäre also er kann sich sehr
wohl ausdrücken und er hat kann sehr
wohl alleine in seinem haus leben also
in dem haus in dem es zeit wachen chance
sozusagen errichtet hat lebte alleine
die sein vater ist gestorben die mutter
und die schwester sind ausgezogen und er
kommt alleine in diesem haus zu recht er
kann alleine von seinen inhalten die auf
youtube teilt liegen also genau er ist
ja auch eine erfolgreiche geschäftsmann
kann man so sagen oder kann man schon
sagen also die angaben in den
verschiedenen gerichtsverfahren was sein
verdienst angeht schwanken zwischen zwei
und 6000 euro nach eigener angabe
und er hat auch kann man denke ich sagen
wenn man diese nicht nennen echten ärger
mit dem finanzamt gehabt weil er seine
steuern nicht gezahlt hat und der
auffassung war für seine youtube content
müsse er keine steuern zahlen und das
kann man ja rechnen wenn man also enorme
schulden beim finanzamt hat dann hat man
natürlich vorher auch erstmal einfluss
einfließen
vielleicht erklären wir erst mal ganz
kurz was der drachen ort denn der ist
reiner ja nun bei youtube denn
eigentlich macht also womit ist dieser
wandel bei youtube berühmt geworden
eigentlich hat er doch mal irgendwann
angefangen so ein bisschen mit gaming
zeugs und uns so ein bisschen eben mit
dieser mit dieser berühmten begrüßung
mädel leute also der hat gesprochen über
gaming so ein bisschen über sein leben
geplappert und über heavy metal musik
oder sie sagen also das war äußerst
unaufgeregt alles hat sich halt selbst
gefehlt wir hätten wir seine metal musik
hört hat dann die musik ein bisschen
eingespielt und eben geschildert dass
ihn das besonders gut gefällt dann hat
er sich selber beim computerspielen
gefehlt hat dazwischen gegessen hat
seinen teller seien leer gegessenen
abgelegt also ist alles ja gut das kann
man jetzt irgendwie sinnvoll finden oder
nicht aber ist ja alles nicht schlimm
und was ist denn dann passiert damit
rainer w irgendwann zu diesem internet
phänomen geworden ist also quasi seitdem
gemobbt wird von hunderten vielleicht
auch tausenden ich glaube das weiß man
gar nicht so genau so genannten hey was
ist da passiert
also ist es eben wie gesagt alles
ziemlich unaufgeregt losgegangen und
alles kein alleinstellungsmerkmal wie
ich jetzt schon versucht habe
zumutung sein entertainment letztlich
aber das ist ja bei vielen youtube an
der fall da
seine wie passiert es ist dass er
plötzlich
negative aufmerksamkeit bekommen hat
also er hat dann angefangen sich
gelegentlich auch frauenfeindlich oder
rassistisch zu äußern und dann gab es
negative aufmerksamkeit und dann ist er
irgendwann ja also er hat eine sehr
kurze zündschnur muss man sagen
und wenn er dann in dialog mit seinen
fans tritt und seine inhalte nicht
goutiert werden dann regt er sich auf
und dann geht er richtig in die luft und
in schon im ersten zu einer erste
aufregung sage ich mal hat er dann seine
adresse ins netz gebrüllt und hat gesagt
man soll doch gefährlich kommen zu ihm
ihn besuchen und er würde dann schon
zitat die scheiße aus den besuchern
herausprügeln
jetzt natürlich der größte anzunehmende
fehler den man beim mobbing machen
können das war richtig darauf einsteigt
und dann ging es richtig los genau und
da auf diese weise ist eben eine
richtige spirale entstanden also er
wurde dann wieder zurück gemobbt und
beschimpft wie er reagiert agiert
ebenfalls wüst und dann hat sich das
eben immer mehr hoch geschaukelt und so
ist dann dieses phänomen sie hatten ja
eingangs mal erwähnt wie kommt
eigentlich dieses cybermobbing in die
echte welt das ist genau an der stelle
passiert er hat eben massiv polarisiert
hat dann wie gesagt die adresse ins netz
hinein green und dann kann die fans
sozusagen
flashmob artig muss man wohl annehmen
beschlossen okay dann pilgern war da mal
hin dass das passiert gibt es denn
eigentlich auch auf der anderen seite
eine richtige fanbase also leute die ihn
verteidigen oder haben wir es hier
inzwischen tatsächlich mit einem
phänomen zu tun alle gegen ein
so wie ich das wahrnehmen oder
wahrgenommen habe stutz nicht auch auf
den bewährungshilfe von den rheiner wie
der eben beschrieben hat in der großen
überwiegenden mehrheit science anti fans
und dieses dieser umstand sei dem
rheiner wie inzwischen auch bewusst
also inzwischen auch bewusst das heißt
am anfang war ist ihm nicht bewusst und
er hat sich so ein bisschen gesund in
der aufmerksamkeit und hat gar nicht
mitbekommen was da eigentlich passiert
oder wie muss man sich das vorstellen
na ja auch das hat der bewährungshelfer
ganz schön erklärt im prinzip ist es so
dass der rainer wie keine echten freunde
hat also keine echten menschen freunde
im realen leben dass der jetzt irgendwie
in sein dorf zum stammtisch gehen würde
oder sowas sondern sein stammtisch ist
tatsächlich das netz und dort sind auch
seines sozialen kontakte und das möchte
er natürlich nicht aufgeben auch weil
finanzielle seite haben wir ja schon
gesprochen auch finanziell seine
lebensgrundlage ist der
bewährungshelfer sagt aber na ja im
prinzip ist diese negative
aufmerksamkeit dieser anti fans die
zahlt sich nicht nur monetär aus sondern
aus der sagte auch nektar emotional weil
er eben in einer großen aufmerksamkeit
hier konfrontiert wird
das ist dann aber diese logik besser
aufmerken besser schlechter
aufmerksamkeit als gar keine
aufmerksamkeit oder wie muss man genau
so fischer vielleicht erkennt ja in
dieser frage gibt es natürlich die
anderen also die spielen ja eben eine
wichtige rolle die hater sie haben sie
ja schon jetzt mehrfach erwähnt
vielleicht beschreiben sie auch noch die
erst mal wer sind diese leute wer kommt
da eigentlich tatsächlich fährt er hing
er in sein kleines dorf da muss man sich
ja wahrscheinlich auch
große mühe machen ja man da kommen wir
nicht einfach so hin wer nimmt das
aufsicht um jemanden zu demütigen
das hört sich ja auch ehrlich gesagt
wahnsinnig
menschenverachtend und zynisch an ja
also wir haben in den
hauptverhandlungen die hater immer
wieder als zeugen erlebt und ich kann
mich jetzt nur darauf stützen weil ich
selber zu dieser community nicht gehöre
und auch nicht in gebiete bin aber aus
diesen sondern vielzahl von zeugen und
da lässt sich im wesentlichen
beschreiben das bleibt in keiner
gesellschaftlichen schicht unbedingt es
gibt gewisse mehrheiten aber es ist
keine homogene gruppe also ich will
sagen in der überwiegenden anzahl fans
junge männer und nicht junge frauen und
bildungsschichten mäßig zieht sich es
auch querbeet also dorf fahren schüler
hin der von studenten hin
menschen die bereits im beruf in lohn
und brot stehen es zieht sich wirklich
durch man kann jetzt nicht sagen dass
das irgendwie in
jugendlichen phänomen ist oder so
sondern tatsächlich junge männer aus
allen bevölkerungskreisen
und die wiederum sind auch
unterschiedlich in ihrem auftreten also
manche machen sich ein sport bitte in
anführungsstrichen zu verstehen daraus
vorzudringen bis zur haustür an dem
anwesen und manche wollen halt nur
gucken und im prinzip muss man sich die
ganze veranstaltung
vorstellen wie so ein großes volksfest
also die attraktion oder das
fahrgeschäft ist sozusagen die drachen
chance und die einwohner die in dieser
ort
blieben und das alles hinnehmen müssen
dann behandelt wie statisten und nicht
wie bewohner ihres eigenen dorfes und
der pilgern halt dann diese anti fees
durch den ort und die kaufen natürlich
die grünen um
die pinkeln an jeden gartenzaun die
werfen eier stinkbomben feuerwerkskörper
alles mögliche auf das anwesen von dem
wie in jeder hat eben eine erklärung und
es vielleicht das interessanteste
behauptet wird
behauptet wurde von zeugen es ginge
darum die chauvinistischen und die
rassistischen ausfälle die wii hat in
die schranken zu weisen also hat sich
selber so weit ging dass das man die
ungebetene besucher sozusagen zum akt
der zivilcourage
umdeklariert hat man müsse schließlich
mal einhalt bieten
und das ist jetzt aber kein psychoterror
oder sowas sondern
hat sich das schon gut gefüllt und das
ist natürlich nicht nur zivilcourage
sondern selbstjustiz muss man sagen das
ist muss man es auch ganz was dahinter
steht herr weiter jetzt wollen wir sie
mal rein bringen vielleicht klären wir
einfach mal einmal vorneweg weil sich
vielleicht die ein oder anderen wundern
warum jetzt der pressesprecher des olg
nürnberg also auch ein richter natürlich
wie so oft es am gericht da überhaupt
einmischt wenn das ja alles dinge sind
die vor dem amtsgericht noch stattfinden
muss man sagen das ganze fand er vor dem
amtsrichter neustadt statt viele
sprechen warum amtsgericht nürnberg es
war so wir haben die verhandlung nach
nürnberg verlegt und zwar aus dem grund
weil einfach das öffentliche interesse
sehr sehr hoch ist und weil wir auch
sicherheitsbedenken geäußert hatten dass
ein sehr kleines amtsgericht und wir
haben in nürnberg einfach eine größere
ausstattung wir sind personell besser
aufgestellt was aufwacht meisterin
wachtmeister anbetrifft und deswegen
fiel die entscheidung nach nürnberg zu
gehen aber auch um journalistinnen und
journalisten hier die möglichkeit zu
geben wir sind immer noch hin pandemie
haben sehr eingeschränktes platzangebot
also haben uns entschieden diesen
prozess tatsächlich in nürnberg
durchzuführen es war aber immer noch das
amtsgericht neustadt mich hat heute der
amtsgerichtspräsident von nürnberg auf
die tollen rezessionen aufmerksam
gemacht die also da momentan das
amtsgericht nürnberg bekommt es ja aber
mit dem fall überhaupt nicht befasst war
es gibt menschen die dieses urteil dann
auch kommentieren kinder und mit tolle
rezensionen meinen sie beschimpft
wahrscheinlich also man muss
unterscheiden es gibt tatsächlich viele
menschen die dieses urteil loben das
sehen wohl diejenigen die ist auch
darauf angelegt hatten den rainer weber
zu
provozieren dass er straftaten begeht
und es gibt umgekehrt natürlich auch
sehr sehr unter die gürtellinie gehen
die kommentare also das ist so ganz
unterschiedlich und ist schon auch
belastend für die justiz sozusagen
insgesamt weil eben die kommentare
teilweise auch sehr bösartig sind und
auch sehr aufs persönliche ziel also
vielleicht können wir das einmal kurz
auseinander sortieren wir sprechen jetzt
von einem verfahren in dem rainer w als
angeklagter auf der anklagebank saß und
zwar wurden ihm mehrere taten zur last
gelegt einerseits
gewalttaten gegenüber sogenannten hätten
die eben mal wieder dieses dorf
eingefallen waren die zum teil auf sein
grundstück eingedrungen sind also er
soll mit einem backstein nach einem von
denen geworfen haben er soll einen in
den schwitzkasten genommen haben ich
glaube da kann ich muss kann ich mir
jetzt auch die die unschuldsvermutung de
formulierung er soll ein wenig sparen
weil er diese taten auch gestanden hat
und sie zum teil eben auch selbst
gefilmt und ins internet gestellt hat
und auf der anderen seite wird ihm zur
last gelegt vor allem verleumdungen und
beleidigungen gegenüber
polizeibeamtinnen und -beamten
denen er dann eben nach sagt die würden
sich nicht hinreichend in ausreichendem
maße vor seinem haus blicken lassen und
dann fielen eben solche sachen wie die
würden nur rumsitzen und am handy zocken
anstatt ihn zu beschützen so also jetzt
kein original zitat sondern das ist in
etwa das was er da eben per video per
youtube rausgehauen hat und dazu würde
ich vielleicht einmal noch gerne frau
befragen diese polizeieinsätze die der
stadt finden das waren ja jetzt nicht
zwei oder drei maliger einsätze sondern
damit man sich glaube ich vorstellen
kann was in diesem sehr kleinen ort los
ist in dem rainer w lebt wie häufig muss
die polizei daraus rücken also von
welchen maßstäben sprechen wir da was
heißt dass erstens für die polizei da
vor ort und zweitens auch für die
menschen die dort leben sie haben vorhin
schon gesagt die werden von den eltern
von den anti fans behandelt wie
statisten
wenn wir dann blick in diesem landkreis
wirft da ist eine p i die hat 50
mitarbeiter diese polizeiinspektion und
ist für eine fläche von 703
quadratkilometern zuständig dort leben
61.000 menschen
und in diesem ort in dem der eine wohnt
leben also 40 und da kommen jeden tag
fünf bis 15 einsätze wander gefahren
also es kommen da jeden tag mindestens
zwei
streifenwagen mit besetzt jeweils mit
zwei beamten dahin die sprechenden
platzverweise ausnehmen anzeigen zu
sachbeschädigungen zu hausfriedensbrüche
nauf und natürlich geht es da auch
beleidigend ziemlich ab also die
belastung ist enorm und ist dann
betrifft das denn also wohnt er jetzt in
einem haus weit draußen auf dem land
oder wohnte er mitten im ort drin also
das heißt inwiefern betrifft das denn
dieses dorf sind da die menschen drum
rum werden die damit reingezogen na ja
wie gesagt das dorf hat 40 einwohner die
die häuser
überschaubar denke ich mal und
der wohnen jetzt nicht auf einem
einsiedler hof der ein kilometer weg ist
sondern natürlich in dem dorf und die
einsätze die fahrzeuge auch rund um die
uhr 24 stunden sieben tage die woche und
das hat man hat ja jeder schon mal
erlebt dass er im in der nähe
blaulicht oder sowas sieht vom haus und
natürlich geht es ins fenster hinein und
man fühlt sich dann die am rummelplatz
und so geht's da auch zu sodann ist der
drachen lord eben mehrfach ausgeflippt
das zeichnet wie gesagt auch aus ich
habe gerade schon gesagt was ihm jetzt
zur last gelegt wurde
herr weiter
warum sind sie denn dieses mal sie haben
das gerade schon angedeutet sozusagen
anders mit dem verfahren umgegangen als
das bisher der fall war wenn ich das
richtig wahrgenommen habe sind die
bisherigen verfahren im umfeld des
drachen lords also sowohl gegen ihn als
auch gegen sogenannte hater die ja auch
schon mehrfach vor gericht gestanden
haben von löw sagte das vorhin immer
relativ zurückhaltend behandelt worden
und in diesem fall haben sie gesagt so
leute jetzt gehen wir ans olg wir
brauchen hier mehr platz wie geben der
pressemitteilung raus wie kam es dazu
man muss vielleicht irgendwann mal so
sagen die strafrechtliche geschichte
sich angucken also es war ja so der
rainer w hat schon vorstrafen das war
aber alles im bagatellbereich und das
hat man dann mit strafbefehl erledigt es
aber jetzt nichts besonderes sondern das
ist ganz normal dass man also bei
erstmals auffälligen personen daneben
mit strafbefehl reagiert das heißt zwar
keine öffentlichen verhandlungen die
verfahren gegen die hacker sind auch
nicht öffentlich geworden war einfach
kein interesse spürbar aber jetzt in den
konkreten fällen war es eben so dass die
sogenannten hessischen vorher immer
wieder angefragt haben dann findet in
die verhandlung gegen rain rwe statt
also wir haben anrufe auf der
pressestelle werden anrufe in neustadt
an der aisch das war einfach klar da
baut sich was auf und in dem moment wo
die menschen auch die ladung zu dem
termin bekommen geht es dann auch das
netz und ist völlig klar wann der termin
stattfindet weil es waren ja auch so
genannte hater als zeugen geladen also
war klar dieser termin wird jetzt
öffentlich werden und dann haben wir uns
entschlossen uns ganz offensiv anzugehen
das ganze so zu organisieren dass mit
dem auch herbert und das ist ganz
einfach auch nicht irgendwie chaotisch
verläuft sondern dass es geordnet
verläuft ist natürlich eine ganz normale
gerichtsverhandlung eigentlich sind sie
auch delikte dir zu in dem klein
kriminalitätsbereiche spielen
beleidigungen körperverletzung
gefährliche körperverletzungen zwar
nichts allerdings sehr sehr viele
straftaten angeklagt so dass dann immer
unterm strich auch eine hohe strafe
rausgekommen ist aber dieses normale
amtsgerichts verfahren wurde eben durch
das öffentliche interesse das schon
vorher spürbar und absehbar so dass wir
gesagt haben wir müssen hier das ganze
besonders behandeln und auch das mediale
echo und jetzt auch das ego danach hat
einfach gezeigt dass wir zu recht zu
gemacht
beschreiben sie doch mal was an diesem
tag an dem verhandlungstag eigentlich
los war bei ihnen die leute haben sich
tatsächlich
angestellt morgens um vier habe ich
gelesen ja da gab es schon die ersten
die sich in reih gestellt haben wir
haben die sich geriert also ich sag mal
so ich habe schon vorher anrufe bekommen
immer mit dem kino ich möchte unbedingt
rein und wir hatten halt schlicht nur 24
plätze 12 für die medien und zwölfte
zuschauen und zuschauer und dann kamen
aus der frage ab wann muss ich da sein
da hab ich gesagt das kann ich ihnen
nicht beantworten weil ich ja nicht
absehen kann man sozusagen die schlange
vor dem gebäude entsteht zwar
tatsächlich so dass ab 4 uhr die ersten
personen da waren das hat sich dann
aufgebaut so auf eine schlange von 60 70
personen die haben sich sehr ordentlich
verhalten also es gab jetzt keine
tumulte oder ähnliche dinge und haben
sich an die regeln gehalten
teilweise wurde schon versucht auch mal
hintenrum ins gebäude reinzukommen und
ähnliche dinge aber unterm strich haben
sich die leute anständig verhalten haben
sich an die regeln gehalten die
aufgestellt waren so dass das sehr sehr
geordnet ab lief aber es war einfach ein
interesse da und ich möchte das
stichwort pizza was fängt schon mal viel
aufgreifen auch an dem verhandlungstag
sind ständig pizza lieferanten
vorgefahren und haben pc verein rw
bringen wollen als ob man sich haben da
die menschen angerufen haben
justizgebäuden in der fürther straße
rainer wimmer stadtspitzen haben wie
auch immer und dann kam also ständig bit
server rainer w also dieser ja
merkwürdig die gags möchte dass man
einen der schon mal 2016 in dem
verfahren eine rolle gespielt hat den
hat mir hier auch weiter fortgesetzt
was sind denn das für menschen also was
für menschen standen da vor gericht an
muss ich mit dir jetzt genauso wie
vorläufig möchte damit niemanden
diskriminieren oder irgendwas muss ich
mir jetzt auch alle als langhaarige
metal fans in zu weiten t shirts
vorstellen was sind das für menschen
kann man die irgendwie charakterisieren
überhaupt nicht als ich versuche es
natürlich immer schwierig wenn man eine
gruppe beschreibt da mag es auch
ausnahmen geben im einzelfall aber
insgesamt das waren ganz überwiegend
männer ich müsste jetzt nachdenken ob
überhaupt eine einzige frau dabei war
vom alter her so 25 bis 30 jahre
vielleicht auch sogar teilweise noch
jünger sind auch viele jugendliche die
da immer mal wieder auftauen
heranwachsende
anständig gekleidet das was anstieg
leitet das natürlich im land ist eine
ansichtssache hemd sakko jeans also ich
habe schon leute erlebt die ganz anders
zu gericht gekommen sind die haben sich
sehr ruhig verhalten es gibt aber
während der verhandlung keine tumulte
oder zwischenrufe es gab so leicht
applaus als dann dieses urteil verkündet
wurde
aber das war insgesamt eine gruppe
junger männer die da letzten endes zu
dieser verhandlung kommen wollte zu der
verhandlung ist es gekommen wenn ich das
richtig verstanden habe denn ich war
selbst auch nicht vor ort weil rainer w
einen vorher im vorgeschlagenen deal
abgelehnt hat ist es richtig das gericht
hat ihn vorgeschlagen dass man sich
verständigen können obwohl er ja schon
straftaten begangen hat während er auf
bewährung war korrekt genau es war so
dass eine verhandlung in neustadt
stattgefunden hat war auch harte kein
öffentliches interesse hervorgerufen das
war ohne zeugen hat erst mal versucht
sage ich mal die sache mit ihm sozusagen
zu gesprächen das sieht ja die
strafprozessordnung auch vor eine
sogenannte verständigung früher haben es
deal genannt jetzt ist kein dem meer
sondern tatsächlich im gesetz geregelt
als verständigung und diese möglichkeit
haben wir hier zunächst mal versucht er
steht ja unter laufender bewährung oder
stand während der straftaten unter
laufender bewährung und natürlich tritt
und gewisser automatismus ein es gibt
auch da ausnahmen das heißt wenn ich
schon mal eine bewährung habe und budget
in dieser bewährung einschlägige
straftaten also straftaten die
vergleichbar sind und es war hier
einfach die bewerbung wegen der
gefährlichen körperverletzung jetzt
waren wie der gefährliche
körperverletzung angeklagt dann gibt es
normalerweise keine bewährung mehr
außerdem hat sogenannte besondere
umstände und da hat die richterin die
zuständig war ihm einfach eine brücke
gebaut und hat gesagt okay wenn du da
wegziehen würdest und da youtube
aktivitäten auf gips oder zumindestens
stark einschränkt dann ist
möglicherweise nicht mehr zu erwarten
dass er weitere straftaten ist und da
wäre dann auch noch die chance auf eine
bewährung das war eigentlich der sinn
dieses damaligen gesprächs er hat ja
dann in der verhandlung im oktober am 21
oktober auch sagt dass er zumindest
diesen hausverkauf jetzt angestoßen hat
er hatte allerdings kein vertrag dabei
also aber auch noch nicht ausgezogen bei
den youtube aktivitäten da hat er nur
davon gesprochen würde irgendetwas
verändern und das war ja auch in der
gesamtschau so dass das gericht dann
gesagt hat okay das sind jetzt keine
besonderen umstände wegen derer ich dir
nochmal bewerbung geben kann sondern
momentan ist die so genannte prognose
die mir dann aufstellen muss also
weiterhin zu straftaten kommen noch nie
negativ und deswegen konnte man auch
keine bewährung wegen aus sicht des
gerichts der dir war ja auch teil der
sehr harschen kritik von sascha lobo da
wollen wir jetzt mal darauf zurückkommen
da gibt er jetzt in der tat ans
eingemachte wir können an dieser stelle
vielleicht bei deutlich sagen ich habe
mehrfach auch sascha lobo zu dieser
sendung gebieten erweitern das hatten
wir im vorfeld ausgesprochen weil sie
auch ein interesse daran gehabt hätten
auch eine große bereitschaft
signalisiert haben sich mit sascha lobo
direkt auseinander zu setzen denn wie
gesagt die vorwürfe des spiegel
kommunisten ging ja sehr weit ich darf
hier vielleicht noch mal kurz was
vorlesen also man kann sehen an dieser
konstellation herr lobo hat erstmal eine
weile lang nicht geantwortet und dann
recht kurz ausrichten lassen dass er
nicht zur verfügung steht für ein
solches gespräch deswegen müssen wir
jetzt können wir ihnen nur zitieren und
das möchte ich hier einmal tun das
schreibt er zu prozessbeginn hatte das
gericht wie einen deal angeboten der
nichts war als eine farce er hätte eine
bewährungsstrafe bekommen wenn er seine
arbeit als internet reizfigur ganz
aufgibt eine täter opfer umkehr und eine
groteske verzerrung der realität denn
die arbeit von w ist es youtube filme zu
machen eine internet reizfigur ist er
weil er gegen seien oft flehend
vorgetragenen willen von tausenden
menschen feinden dazu gezwungen wurde
verdient sein geld mit seinen netz
auftritten er kann nichts anderes das
aufzugeben würde ihn ins nicht stürzen
genau dorthin wo ihm die heeder in ihrem
vernichtungs war waren haben wollen war
das ein menschenverachtender vorschlag
erweitert
also muss vielleicht zunächst mal sagen
dass das inhaltlich insofern falsch ist
als zu beginn dieser verhandlung über
die der herr lobo schreibt er war ja
nicht da nicht das gericht eine
verständigung angeboten hat sondern
tatsächlich die verteidigung dieser
initiative gesucht hat und man hat dann
noch mal ein gespräch geführt also die
initiative ging von der verteidigung aus
und dieser vorschlag den muss man also
vor dem hintergrund sehen erstand oder
laufender bewährung die richterin wollte
ihm einen weg aufzeigen wie könnte es
noch einmal zu einer bewegung kommen und
die einzige chance die man da war eben
wegziehen des youtube verhalten stark
verändern um dann eben auch wieder quasi
neuen start hinlegen zu können und eben
sagen zu können okay du kriegst nochmal
bewegen was die absolute ausnahme ist
wenn jemand unter bewährung steht gibt
es nochmals keine zweite bewährung
ausnahmen bestätigen die regel und zone
ausnahme wollte man hier schaffen und
das sind natürlich dann auch besondere
maßnahmen notwendig manche menschen und
ziehen sich dann noch mal eine kur
manche menschen verändern völlig ihre
lebensverhältnisse also dass auch gar
nichts ungewöhnliches das war einfach
ein weg den man ihm aufzeigen wollte und
diese brücke hat er da nicht
überschritten weil er vielleicht auch
selber gesagt okay ich liebe ja letzten
endes davon ich weiß im übrigen gar
nicht das ist jetzt natürlich eine
meinung diskussion ob die hater
tatsächlich wollen dass er mit dem
youtube verhalten aufhört die wollten
ihn sicher im gefängnis sehen zumindest
von dem teil immer wieder so propagiert
worden aber viele hat man das gefühl
sind auch so ein bisschen abhängig von
ihm die brauchen ihn auch aus welchen
gründen auch immer und deswegen ob die
wirklich wollen dass er damit auch für
das ist auch wieder die von der von löw
angesprochen die zivilcourage die hier
behauptet das bin ich zumindest nicht
sicher aber dass jetzt auch noch eine
meinungsäußerung von mir
aber das ist vielleicht auch ein
wichtiger punkt den sie da gemacht haben
also justiz will durchaus auch erziehen
oder jedenfalls zu einem gewissen
lebenswandel
anregen das passiert auch in anderen
konstellationen wissen vielleicht auch
viele nicht dass es durchaus auch er im
lebenshilfe ist jetzt wahrscheinlich so
ein bisschen zu viel gesagt aber
jedenfalls man auch bemüht ist die
richterin bemüht war ihn auf eine spur
zu lenken die sie als etwas sinnvolles
gesehen hat darf ich an der stelle noch
was ergänzen gerne
ich war tatsächlich vor ort als die
richterin das vorgeschlagen hat und zwar
bereits als die verhandlung als die
begann war die ursprünglich am
amtsgericht in neustadt an der aisch
selbst da hatte man ja noch keine zeugen
geladen sondern eben versucht mit im
gespräch mit dem rainer w diesen ganzen
komplex in einem schlag zu lösen also im
prinzip muss man ja sehen die anwohner
in dem dorf sind sauer auf die justiz
und auf die politik was auch immer jetzt
die politik ausrichten könnte aber sie
sind eben tatsächlich sauer weil sie
sich im stich gelassen fühlen und der
meinungs- in ihnen wird in den
belagerungszustand ihres dorfes nicht
geholfen so und die sehen den dreien rw
natürlich auch als mobbingopfer sehen
aber auch dass er mit seinen aktivitäten
immer neue die ursache setzt und die
hätte ja auch anlockt und aus dem grund
und dann hat er noch hohe schulden bei
der gemeinde selbst da geht es wiederum
um kanalanschluss gebühren und aus dem
grund gab es schon früher ein
kaufangebot der gemeinde was das anwesen
von den rheiner wie angeht
und eine gewisse bereitschaft von den
rheiner wie auch tatsächlich eck zu
ziehen und diesen punkt an die richterin
eben auch aufgegriffen also ist es nicht
so dass sie den von sich aus aus dem
dorf vertreiben wollte sondern sie hat
was aufgegriffen was ohnehin schon
bekannt und in der welt werden und
offensichtlich von seiner verteidigung
ja auch noch angeregt wurde genau da
kombinierte sich testern und rainer w
selbst hat darüber fabuliert dass er die
art und weise seine youtube videos ja
verändern könnte also das war alles in
der welt das hat sich nicht die
richterin ausgedacht sondern wie eben
jetzt schon zu recht angemerkt wurde es
wurde von der verteidigung vorgebracht
aber eben auch von rainer w selbst
was natürlich auch noch wichtig ist
vermutlich dafür auch dass rainer w dann
erst mal diese verständigung abgelehnt
hat ist ja die tatsache dass er sich
selbst nicht als so genannten
bewährungsversager sieht dieses wort ist
ein ganz normales wort innerhalb der
justiz das scheint er aber sehr
persönlich genommen zu haben also ich
hab da mal in seine youtube videos auch
rein gehört da ist sogar auch ein
bisschen aber was dran denn die
sozialstunden zu deren ableistung er
zunächst verurteilt worden ist also in
den ehemaligen verfahren aus dem jahr
2019 glaube ich die hat er ja teilweise
wirklich nicht ableisten können wenn ich
das richtig verstanden habe weil ihn
keiner einrichtung dafür aufnehmen
wollte ist das richtig ja es ist völlig
richtig dass kommen auch im prozess
tatsächlich zur sprache da bei der
bewährungshelfer regelrecht verzweifelt
also der nrw an der stelle kann man ihm
wirklich kein versagen vorwerfen kein
bewährungsversager wurde von keiner
einzigen ins schon angenommen weil man
befürchtet hat wenn der kommt kommen im
gefolge die hater kommen im gefolge die
medien und das wollte man vermeiden
und in der gewissen verzweiflung
es war schon fast unfreiwillig komisch
hat dann der bewährungshelfer angeboten
der rainer w könnte ja auch den hof vom
amtsgericht kehren
das ist in der tat irgendwie tragisch
komisch auf der anderen seite wie so
vieles in diesem gesamtkomplex hat auch
das wieder eine andere seite ist er
damals auch dazu verurteilt worden ein
anti aggressionstraining wahrzunehmen
das ist ja auch ein relativ normales
vorgehen innerhalb eines strafverfahrens
wenn man eben einfach weiß dass jemand
sehr leicht in die luft geht oder eine
sehr kurze zündschnur sagt hat wie sie
sagen frau läuft an diesem anti
aggressions training hat er nicht
teilgenommen das hat in nürnberg statt
gefunden und da hat er damit
argumentiert er hätte sich die fahrt
nicht leisten können das ist jetzt wenn
man mal ihm unterstellt dass es
zumindest in teilen korrekt ist dass er
6000 euro brutto im monat eine mit
seinen youtube einnahmen ja nun auch
wieder etwas merkwürdig also dass man
sich daran keine fahrt nach nürnberg
leisten kann ist ein bisschen
zweifelhaft oder also auch da mal wieder
zweischneidiges schwert genau völlig
richtig und dessen dann natürlich wieder
die anlässe die die hater sehr gern
aufgreifen um zu belegen dass er eben
nicht nur ein opfer ist sondern auch
die justiz an der nahe herumführt
so nach einem kurzen technischen fail
sind wir wieder da und hoffen dass sich
keine oder keine von uns anders anhört
als zuvor wir setzen da weiter an wo wir
waren und wir waren ja stehen geblieben
bei der verständigung zu der es am ende
nicht gekommen ist sondern reiner w ist
verurteilt worden und zwar zu einer
gesamtfreiheitsstrafe von zwei jahren
die eben nicht zur bewährung ausgesetzt
wurde wegen mehrfacher beleidigung wegen
gefährlicher körperverletzung in zwei
fällen und wegen verleumdung und
beleidigung von polizeibeamten
dieses urteil ist nicht leicht gewesen
hat die richterin bei der
urteilsbegründung gesagt der youtuber
seit täter und opfer zugleich ein
trauriges beispiel dafür welche folgen
hass und mobbing im internet haben es
gebe menschen die sich daran ergötzen
ihnen psychisch fertig zu machen und zu
provozieren hat die richterin kritisiert
er begebe sich aber auch selbst immer
wieder in die schusslinie ich fand es
eine sehr prägnante und einfache
zusammenfassung dessen was ebenso
umstritten ist und ich finde es sehr
spannend denn dieses urteil mal
reinzuschauen weil eigentlich ich finde
dass ich in dieser urteilsbegründung
genau diese zwiespältigkeit sehr wohl
findet und dass der vorwurf den unter
anderem sascha lobo du hast du schon
erwähnt corinna massiv verhoben hat dass
dieses urteil quasi ein mobbing
fortsetzt und eine täter opfer rolle
umkehren würde eigentlich sich schon aus
dem urteil relativ gut widerlegen lässt
denn die richterin hat sehr detailliert
für dafür dass es eigentlich um mir
relativ geringfügige vorwürfe geht
schulbuchmäßig alles durchgeprüft also
sie hat bei jeder part geprüft ob rainer
w in notwehr gehandelt hat ob er im
rechtfertigen notstand war oder aus
irgendwelchen gründen eingeschränkt
schuldfähig war
rainer wie selbst fühlt sich ja
eigentlich permanent um juristisch
ausgedrückt als wäre in einem
permanenten not in einer permanenten
notwehrlage herr weiter warum hat die
richterin das anders gesehen die notwehr
ist ein gesetz geregelt und einfach
bestimmte voraussetzungen nämlich man
braucht einen gegenwert rechtswidrigen
angriff und daran scheitert es
eigentlich schon in allen fällen denn es
war eine beleidigungen soll die leitung
nicht gutheißen aber seine beleidigung
kann man dann nicht dadurch wären dass
wir irgendwie minuten später nach unten
geht und jemand vielleicht mit der
taschenlampe ins gesicht schlägt im
übrigen können die straftaten
überwiegend außerhalb des grundstücks
staat sonst können die man vielleicht
darüber reden dass hier ein
hausfriedensbruch abgewehrt werden soll
sondern es waren schläge durch den zaun
hindurch und an diesen gegenwärtigen
rechtswidrigen angriff hat es aber aus
sicht der richterin und ja das ja sehr
ausführlich dargelegt jedes mal gefehlt
hinzu kommt dass man haushalt wenn man
staatliche hilfe in anspruch nehmen kann
also immer die möglichkeit hat und da
kann auch darunter fallen die polizei
ruft und die zeitnahe kommt dass auch
dann keine not will quasi vorliegt also
auch das hat die richterin hier geprüft
das muss man ja auch sagen es kommt ja
täglich das haben wir schon gesprochen
zu provokationen und die polizei kommt
sehr oft und hilft dann dem einer wie
auch und aus diesem grund liegt hier
eben einfach keine novelle vor also es
scheint schon am gegenwärtigen
rechtswidrigen angriff wenn wir es aber
nur zusätzlich nicht erforderlich war
mir aber staatliche hilfe in anspruch
nehmen kann und sagen kann da stehen
zwei küken auf der straße die mich
gerade aufs übelste beleidigt das sage
ich gar kein problem da jemanden zu
rufen und ich lege wert darauf dass über
150 verfahren bei der staatsanwaltschaft
gibt 150 verfahren wenn nicht immer
gleich zu einer anklageerhebung oder
ähnlichen dingen sind für jugenddelikte
dabei da gibt es ja dann verschiedene
arten wie man das erledigen kann sich
der binger mahnung viele verfahren
werden da noch abgegeben da kommt es
immer auf den grundsatz an aber wir
haben auch verurteilungen also die
gleiche richterin hat beispielsweise
einen angeklagt zu neun monaten
freiheitsstrafe allerdings mit bewährung
da waren die voraussetzung noch andere
verurteilt es ist keineswegs so dass
diese menschen für den straffrei
ausgehen sondern justiz verfolgt eben
straftaten wenn sie begangen werden und
es ist völlig egal ob durch eine weg
oder durch irgendwelche anti fans
straftaten müssen verfolgt werden wenn
keine oper vorliegt kann man auch keine
notwehr annehmen das wäre rechtsbeugung
also wichtiger aspekt den sie ansprechen
das heißt diese hater wurden auch in
vielen fällen angeklagt die wurden zum
teil auch verurteilt das wurde aber
natürlich medial überhaupt nicht
kolportiert weil das ja im prinzip nicht
relevant ist das hat auf deutsch gesagt
keiner mit bekommen richtig und dadurch
entsteht auch dieses gefühl dass der
drachen lord quasi jetzt der angeklagte
täter ist während den helfern nichts
passiert genauso ist es wurde medial
überhaupt nicht begleitet das würde das
eine verfahren begleitet von ihm die
rolle schon gesprochen hatte in dieser
mehrjährigen haftstrafen aus dem jahr
2016 weil er da das wort team er
geschickt hat das haben wir
entschuldigung für hin leider offen
gelassen vielleicht um das einmal
deutlich zu sagen den fall den von löw
am anfang geschildert hat wo es um
dieses mobbing vorwürfe geht wo sie
herrn wie zum ersten mal gesehen hat das
ist in einer mehrjährigen haftstrafe für
den täter beendet wie viele der vier
jahre damals bekommen da waren um andere
straftaten angeklagt also das internet
betrügereien aber das war ein ganz
markante geschichte und ich mir sehr
sehr gut erinnern ich habe auch diesen
fall schon begleitet wird man als
pressesprecher der richter hat damals in
der urteilsbegründung ganz massiv diese
spotting kurve ins zentrum gestellt ich
erinnere mich an die einzelstaaten das
waren einmal der tat insgesamt viermal
die feuerwehr ausdrücken lassen zudem
rein rw weil er sich auch wahnsinnig
lustig ist anführungszeichen jetzt
gesetzt wenn der gerade auf youtube ist
und wer sich kommt die feuerwehr und da
gab es einzelstrafen und sechs monaten
einmal um drei mal fünf monate sind sehr
sehr hohe strafen für dieses voting
aktion das ist ja nur ein missbrauch von
notrufen und da ist der strafraums schon
sehr niedrig also da hat er richtig
eingegriffen weil das eben auch schon
als form des mobbings damals empfunden
hat und dann muss man jetzt sagen die
anderen hater da ist es nicht so da sind
sehr viele jugendliche dabei wer nach
jugendrecht auch abgeholt hat es in der
terrorist nichtöffentliche
strafverfahren und das ist ein denke ich
der grund warum das ganze bislang in der
öffentlichen betrachtung überhaupt keine
rolle gespielt hat so man spricht immer
nur von der verurteilung wegen einer weg
weil das natürlich auch medial tages
abgefeiert wurde von leuten die das land
genau darauf angelegt hatten also mit
mails und danach im internet und diese
anderen verurteilungen sind nicht zur
sprache gekommen
die fehlten mir auch so ein bisschen in
der kommentierung die dann nach dem
urteil teilweise eben hier erfolgt ist
das ein wichtiger hinweis aber ich
glaube das muss man vielleicht auch noch
mal ein mal deutlich erklären weil also
die ja diese ganze psychische belastung
die herr lobo ja auch hervorgehoben hat
die das gericht keinesfalls ignoriert
hat sondern ganz dezidiert geprüft hat
einmal in der not wer eine frage hat da
eine notwehr vorgelegen und dann später
noch mal bei den strafmilderungsgründe
da kommen wir vielleicht gleich noch zu
aber man muss vielleicht einmal noch mal
das genau erklären weil ich interessant
fand ich habe auch beim lesen das gefühl
gehabt das wird natürlich alles sehr
nüchtern abgehandelt das wird wie es im
juristischen stil urteilt stil der auch
notwendig ist natürlich auch nicht
emotional besonders sympathisch
dargelegt und ich glaube das was leute
wie sascha lobo daran kritisiert haben
ist also ich weiß gar nicht genau was
eigentlich herr lobo wollte das hat er
nicht dezidiert gesagt ich weiß gar
nicht ob er wollte dass es eine
bewährungsstrafe wiedergibt oder ob
nicht doch eher ein freispruch dabei
rauskommen sollte seiner ansicht nach
aber um das einmal deutlich zu sagen
also auch selbst eine psychische
belastung die so dramatisch ist wie sie
wahrscheinlich im fall von rainer wie
die über jahre hinweg war wo sich
irrsinnig viel aufgebaut hat kann im
strafverfahren aber nur an diesen beiden
stellen eine rolle spielen nämlich bei
der notwehr und dann später auch bei den
strafmilderungsgründe oder gibt es
irgendeine andere möglichkeit die das
strafverfahren lässt der strafe war eine
sehr sehr stringentes verfahren ist aus
meiner sicht tatsächlich kaum
möglichkeiten zu sowas zu
berücksichtigen wenn jetzt keine not
waste hat die kollegin ausführlich
geprüft dann kann es in der
strafzumessung berücksichtigen wenn das
ganze dazu führt dass man vielleicht
vermindert schuldfähig wäre war auch mit
dem thema sicher auseinandergesetzt dann
könnte man das auch berücksichtigen und
natürlich kann man wenn man jemanden
bewährung gibt im hilfe geben und es ist
auch versucht worden weil der ersten
bewährungsstrafe beispielsweise mit
einem bewährungshelfer aber ansonsten
sind die möglichkeit das wurde auch von
dem justiz versagen die justiz kann
eigentlich nur im rahmen der hier zur
verfügung stehenden möglichkeiten dinge
tun und nicht irgendwie daneben noch
irgendwie helfen was aus meiner sicht
den aspekt muss ich schon noch einführen
man hier beachten muss keiner der fälle
des cyber mobbings ist auch vielleicht
dieses voting anrufe war bislang
gegenstand also weder den äußerungen von
dem rheiner wie in irgendeiner form der
teilweise auch strafrechtlich relevant
gewesen sein könnten noch von den eltern
und verwandten wir haben hier quasi ein
cyber mobbing das zum real mobbing
geworden ist sind diese real möglichen
fälle also dieses treffen vor ort das
sind die dinge die wir jetzt letzten
endes als thema haben dass das thema
cybermobbing da könnte man lange darüber
diskutieren was hat es da überhaupt für
möglichkeiten dass wir da auch grenzen
haben auch schwierigkeiten haben dieses
ganze hate speech überhaupt griff zu
bekommen da wird sich sehr bemüht und
erschafft man auch neue ernormen wir
können auch immer nur die gesetze
anwenden zur verfügung stehen ihren
urlaub hörner sine lege
dass sich ein ganz großes thema und dass
da vielleicht auch dinge geändert werden
müssen dass man das kritisieren kann das
ist sehe ich genauso aber wir haben hier
real mobbingfälle vor der tür und
jemanden der auf diese fälle reagiert in
einer art und weise die dann leider
strafrechtlich relevant wird und dann
bleibt nichts anderes übrig als hier
auch diese straftaten zu verurteilen und
zwar so wie man jeden anderen auch
verurteilen würde aber das haben wir
schon angesprungen der strafzumessung
kann man da natürlich auch
berücksichtigen dass eben vorher
provokationen stattgefunden haben und
das hat die richterin getan ich habe das
urteil vor mir da heißt zum beispiel die
provokationen der geschädigten
überschritten selbst die grenze zur
strafbarkeit also haben sie selber
strafbar gemacht und zielten in
menschenverachtender weise ganz bewusst
auf die persönlichen wunden punkte des
angeklagten also selbst hinter wie sie
gesagt haben wir nur eins nüchtern
gehaltenen details kunden kommt doch
noch mal das sehr deutlich zum ausdruck
dass tiere ich denke dass hier sehr wohl
gesehen hat dieses mobbing dass man
gegenüber dem rennen gegangen hat ich
würde sogar corinna an dieser stelle
widersprechen wollen weil sich ja im
urteil sogar die formulierung findet das
rheiner wie sich hinreißen ließ ist
unabhängig von der dogmatischen frage
der strafrechtlichen rechtfertigung
menschlich nachvollziehbar ich finde das
ist sogar für ein juristisches ist es
quasi ein emotionaler ausbruch und ich
finde einfach die häufigsten vorbildlich
erklären in der juristen welt schon aber
in natürlich auf dem laufenden
auf der straße würde man das anders
sehen das ist schon alles sehr nüchtern
gehalt ich will das auch überhaupt nicht
kritisieren aber dass sprang mir so ein
bisschen ins gesicht wo ich das einfach
das gefühl hat dass muss man vielleicht
noch mal da muss man nochmal einen
schritt zurücktreten und das noch mal
erklären aber das haben sie jedenfalls
jetzt wunder dass schon angedeutet herr
weiter es wurde ja durchaus auch nur
eingeschränkte schuldfähigkeit überprüft
frau löw hat es schon gesagt also reiner
b hat die sonderschule abgeschlossen und
es gab wohl offensichtlich sogar mal ein
gutachten das erstellt worden ist in der
überlegung dass er möglicherweise unter
betreuung gestellt werden muss dazu kam
ist aber nicht und die richterin hat
eben jetzt gesagt na ja wir brauchen
nicht nur keine betreuung sondern eine
intelligenzminderung kann zwar
grundsätzlich zu einer eingeschränkten
schuldfähigkeit führen aber eben nur in
dem fall dass man wirklich von einer
erheblichen intelligenzminderung zum
beispiel sprechen würde und dafür gibt
es jetzt bei rainer w glaube ich keine
anhaltspunkte die da auch nur irgendwie
in die nähe kommen werden ist das
richtig also zumindest aus sicht der
damaligen hauptverhandlung gab es keine
anhaltspunkte gutachten jetzt zu holen
man hat den einer wie auch in der
verhandlungen erlebt es doch so dass der
seine dinge auch zum ausdruck bringen
kann er hat ja anwalt hatte er für ihn
das geständnis abgegeben das hat er noch
ein bisschen relativiert dann gab es
noch mal ein gespräch da unser aus
meiner sicht ja klug ist in der
situation letztes wort gesagt und auf
eine formulierung hier also es gibt
jetzt keine anhaltspunkte dass mir von
der verminderten schuldfähigkeit bei den
straftaten auch ausgehen kann ob man
jetzt in der berufungsverhandlung die er
dann im märz in nürnberg stattfinden
wird möglicherweise auch in die richtung
noch mal vertieft der cookies hang
gefällt auch davon dass die verteidigung
jetzt auch bringt dann an
angriffspunkte gegen das urteil das wird
man sehen müssen also für die jura
nachts da draußen es wurde auch geprüft
der rechtfertigenden notstand und
abgelehnt nach 34 stgb auch mit dem
argument dass die gefahr an das
abwendbar gewesen wäre hätte einfach
weil weise im haus bleiben können und
oder darauf warten dass die ja schon
gerufene polizei eintraf das war immer
wieder das argument
dass er sich praktisch nicht hätte
provozieren lassen müssen dass er
einfach hätte im haus bleiben können und
es wurde auch noch der entschulden den
notstand geprüft nach 35 strafgesetzbuch
es lag aber keine gefahr für leben leib
oder freiheit vor in diesem fall und
deshalb hat die zuständige richterin
seine strafbarkeit bejaht und jeweils
kurze freiheitsstrafen
verhängt ist insgesamt zu einer
gesamtfreiheitsstrafe von zwei jahren
gekommen und hat dann durchaus wie ich
finde relativ ausführlich
strafmildernde und straff schärfen de
umstände dargelegt und da ging es halt
eben auch schon sehr viel um diese
psychische belastungssituation der
rheiner wie seit jahren ausgelöst
ausgesetzt ist es ging auch um seine
sehr besondere persönlichkeitsstruktur
weil er eben wie sie frau hinter vorhin
sagten frau relativ schnell hoch geht
aber es ging eben auch ganz viel um die
hacker die ihn aus sensationslust
aufgesucht haben genau diese leichte
reizbarkeit ausgenutzt haben um ihn zu
provozieren und die sich ja auch
widerrechtlich zumindest in teilen auf
seinem grundstück befanden herr weiter
es gab aber durchaus auch gesichtspunkte
die das gericht strafschärfend
berücksichtigt hat ich denke dass hier
zwei komplexe unterscheiden wir haben
einmal dieses
vorgehen gegen die hater die ihn
provoziert haben und da hat es gibt sehr
sehr viele milderungsgründe gesehen aber
wir haben auf der anderen seite auch
diese beleidigung irgendwie
polizeibeamten und die sind nun wahrlich
nicht fein muss man ganz klar sagen also
da wird auch in die verbal sprache
gegriffen und diese polizeibeamtin
polizei werben tun ja nichts anders als
ihre arbeit fahren sie mal wieder raus
beschützen auch den herrn rainer w und
da hat das gericht gesagt dass es
überhaupt nicht angezeigt auch eine
wirken einer art und weise auf die
polizeibeamten im übrigen auch teilweise
in live streams mit 30.000 zuschauern
zuschauen loszugehen in dem punkt war
das gericht auch sehr sehr deutlich dass
es eben die punkte wo es um beleidigung
gegenüber polizeibeamten gegen sehr
strafschärfend berücksichtigt hat eben
die tatsache dass die nichts anderes tun
als ihre arbeit im letzten endes auch
helfen wollen das war glaube ich bei der
strafzumessung letzten endes wesentlich
gewichtiger als diese von den eltern
provozierten straftaten das ist ein sehr
interessanter aspekt den hatte ich den
ort also gar nicht so entnommen das
heißt da die strafzumessung also dass
die strafe dann doch recht hoch
ausgefallen ist fühlen sie durchaus auch
vor allem auf die straftaten zum
nachteil der polizeibeamtinnen vor ort
zurück man kann ja an den einzelnen
strafen verhängt wurden sehen wie die
richterin das jeweils gewichtet hat und
eine beleidigung hat hier eine maximale
freiheitsstrafe wenn es keine tätliche
beleidigung ist von bis zu einem jahr
und da sind dann doch durch als kurze
freiheitsstrafen verhängt worden da
sieht man klar diese punkte sind bei der
strafzumessung also wir sind sehr stark
bewertet worden wenn man hingegen bei
den angriffen das ist eben ein
gefährlicher körperverletzung da mal
mindeststrafe von sechs monaten das darf
man nicht vergessen dass der wirt der
strafraum ganz anderer ist da hat man
eher in die untere region gegriffen wenn
also bei der beleidigung ist uns ins
mitteln in dem mittleren bereich was
kann er unglücklich ist während man bei
der gefährlichen körperverletzung sich
eher am unteren rand orientierten da
sieht man doch sehr deutlich dass die
richterin eben dieses provozierenden
dieses wochenstart zu seinen gunsten
berücksichtigt hat umgekehrt aber gab es
überhaupt keinen grund polizei wir haben
den polizeibeamten zu beleidigen noch
dazu öffentlich und im übrigen auch in
einer sehr sehr guten angemessenen art
und weise die richterin hat aber auch in
bezug auf die körperverletzungen also
zum nachteil der hacker
durch ausgesagt dass sie berücksichtigt
hat dass der angeklagte von dieser
hacker szene auch lebt weil davon eben
seine reichweite bei youtube
fast also sagen wir mal zumindest in
ganz weiten teilen auf diese hacker
szene zurückzuführen wir haben das
vorhin schon besprochen frau lief sie
sagten auch schon es gibt eigentlich
maximalen kleinen teil von ihnen positiv
gestimmten verloren es gibt aber einen
ganz ganz großen anteil dieser großen
reichweite die ihn dann dazu führt dass
werbung geschaltet wird und dass man
davon leben kann das sind die hater und
das hat die richterin schon
berücksichtigt auch strafschärfend dass
der angeklagte sich dessen sehr bewusst
ist dass er von dieser aufmerksamkeit
diese szene nicht nur profitiert sondern
dass er davon sogar finanziell lebt
genau darf ich darauf noch eine antwort
geben ich bin der auffassung dass man
genau an dem punkt wie ihre einer wie
mit den polizisten umspringt und zu
welchen ausfällen verbaler art er sich
da hinreißen lässt ganz gut sehen kann
wie er auch tickt also erst mal geht er
davon aus dass ihm so eine art 24
stunden polizeischutz auch zustimmt also
der behandelt der tatsächlich die
polizeiinspektion wie seinen privaten
sicherheitsdienst und wenn die nicht im
null komma null angerückt sind dann tobt
und schimpft er und halb youtube schaut
dann zu und man kann jetzt natürlich
sagen dass man nach jahrelangen mobbing
gereizt ist ja
dass mir verzweifelt also bereits klingt
jetzt nicht ich glaube es beide niedlich
also ich glaube es tatsächlich beides
bietet gereizt und er ist verzweifelt
aber
ob man daraus setzt der rechtfertigung
ableiten muss das nur unbedingt
weitermachen muss in seinem tun weil die
polizei mit 50 mitarbeitern sozusagen
immer gewehr bei fuß steht wenn er was
braucht das ist schon auch grenzwertig
und an der stelle sagte auch mal sein
bewährungshelfer
würde sich rainer w längstens in dieser
opferrolle auch eingerichtet haben weil
er sich in dieser rolle dann aus der
verantwortung auch herausnehmen kann ja
und man merkt parallel das oder dass
seine clique zugriffszahlen hochgehen
wenn er besondere ausfälle zum besten
gibt also wenn der rassistisch sich
äußert antisemitisch oder
frauenfeindlich oder über sex mit tieren
spricht das ist alles nicht schön aber
da steigen natürlich seine
zugriffszahlen da empören sich die hater
an der stelle und die spirale dreht sich
noch schneller und er fühlt sich dann
als opfer aber man sieht eben dass er
sich an der stelle auch dieser
zugriffszahlen
völlig bedient also dass diese empörung
die er erzeugt sozusagen teil von seinem
geschäftsmodell wird
ich könnte das auch für den cyber
bereich komplett nachvollziehen aber es
ist ja immerhin noch was anderes da rein
zu klicken und quasi die klickzahlen zu
generieren teil dieser gruppe zu sein
die da rein klickt und dann auch dafür
sorgt dass er ordentlich werbeeinnahmen
bekommt aber auf der anderen seite finde
ich es schon noch interessant und ein
phänomen und ehrlich gesagt auch
wirklich hanebüchen dass es über jahre
hinweg nicht möglich ist die leute von
diesem pilgertouren zu seinem haus
zurückzuhalten warum da würde ich
vielleicht sascha lobo durchaus recht
gehen zu sagen warum versagt der staat
denn was sind denn die option also wenn
ich das richtig weiß dann wurden ja
durchaus schon auch massnahmen ergriffen
vor ort ist wo es gab ja so eine art
bannmeile und so weiter an diesem ort
die menschen nicht gehalten haben oder
ich weiß nicht verläuft da sind sie
jetzt wirklich lokal sehr gut informiert
da hat ja die polizei durchaus dinge
versucht oder ja ich bin völlig bei
ihnen was sind denn die optionen der ort
hatten der allgemeinverfügung erlassen
da darf sich niemand da dürfen sich
nicht mehr mehr als neun leute
versammeln das ist ja schon mal ne harte
maßnahmen in corona zeiten vielleicht
weniger aber früher habe ich doch keiner
genau
aber es hält sich doch keiner dran oder
mehr dann kommen die polizei ist an
platzverweise erteilt es wenn
ordnungsgelder verhängt auch in corona
zeiten pilgern der menschen noch hin
verstoßen natürlich gegen die hygiene
auflagen auch da wann ordnungsgelder
verhängt es wird natürlich gehandelt die
justiz auch das haben wir schon
besprochen klagt hat ja nicht nur den
drei neue angeklagt sondern auch eine
reihe von verfahren gegen härter geführt
über die dann natürlich nur die lokale
presse berichtet
dafür reist kein überregionales medium
an es auch nachvollziehbar nur es kommen
dann eben eine andere ein anderes
narrativ in die welt die erzählung das
nun wird der rheiner straße erfolgt wird
die medien also wir haben für unser
verlagshaus irgendwann begonnen ihn
abzukürzen ihn nicht mehr mit vollem
namen zu nennen
ich frag mich jetzt auch tatsächlich was
mehr hätte denn geschehen sollen also es
wurden beispielsweise auch versuche
unternommen
mit ihm zu sprechen also von gänzlich
unbeteiligten personen im sinn einer
versuchten vermittlung auch dies sind
gescheitert weil wie gesagt beim
geringsten anlass auch in die luft geht
möchte ich aber offensichtlich scheint
jetzt auch diese ab diese für
strafverfahren gegenüber den hater nicht
zu einer abschreckenden wirkung zukommt
ich nicht aber ich frage mich auch
tatsächlich wenn man von dem versagen
spricht der allgemeinheit der justiz der
medien der polizei der ordnungsbehörden
welche handlungsoptionen hätten wir denn
in
der tat ich frage mich das auch so ein
bisschen zumal das man man das ja
durchaus auch mal öffentlich rechtlich
denken könnte und sich fragen könnte wer
ist denn hier eigentlich der störer sind
die hater die störer ist vielleicht auch
reinhard ins definitiv auch also ich
glaube daran gedacht kann ist das war
eigentlich die hater sind auf jeden fall
täter strafrechtlich gesehen öffentlich
rechtlich gesehen sind sie störe man
könnte vielleicht das auch mal durchaus
weiter denken und sich fragen ist denn
rainer w nicht derjenige der durch
dadurch dass er immer weitermacht und
die spirale zumindest meine ich runter
eskaliert ich formuliere das mal
freundlich derjenige der für eine
dauerhafte störung immer wieder sorgt
und ich meine viel mehr
als die polizei behördlichen behörden
vor ort machen kann man glaube ich nicht
tun vor allem weil wir ja nicht davon
sprechen dass das alle drei monate mal
passiert sondern täglich also noch mehr
als allgemein verfügung zu erlassen oder
so da sehe ich einfach nicht was der
staat mehr tun könnte ich sehe da
eigentlich kein echtes massives
staatsversagen herr weidner haben sie
noch ideen was der staat da tun könnte
also was ich vielleicht noch zunächst
mal ergänzen möchte ganz viele
personen die jetzt gerade auch bei
diesen straftaten beteiligt waren waren
alkoholisiert also man hat auch diese
geschichte gehört wir waren auf dem
weihnachtsmarkt in neustadt und
entfernten nacht zum also dass ich was
noch mit zucken und läuft dann allen
ernstes ist auch noch eine ganze ecke
weiter weg über den anderen ort jetzt
nicht nennen
durch dann auch noch mal eine ganze ecke
bis man tatsächlich da ist an der stelle
ist an der rheiner wohnt und das macht
also kilometer weit muss man dann noch
laufen und trotzdem machen die leute das
und wenn natürlich der alkohol die
vernunft ausschalten dann ist natürlich
auch schwer mit mit staatlichen
maßnahmen die machen das dann trotzdem
wir haben auch ordnungswidrigkeiten
sogar zivilrechts urteile weil dinge
kaputt gemacht worden sind und mehr kann
jetzt die justiz nicht tun die stadt die
gemeinde hat versucht mit der
allgemeinen verwirrung zu reagieren ich
sehe eigentlich kaum möglichkeiten und
das war vielleicht auch so die idee der
kolleginnen die damals gesagt der mensch
der einzige weg ist er zieht weg ist ja
auch eine unendliche spirale wenn das so
weitergeht wird das ja nie aufhören dass
das spürt man ja die urteile gegen haye
das sind immer nur singuläres eine
strafe die nimmt man halt mal mit da
kommt man dann noch mal hin wenn man
noch mal hin käme würde man tatsächlich
auch ohne bewährung bekommen aber das
nächste mal kommt der nächste und die
nächste also sind keine
wiederholungstäter das ist ja vielleicht
auch wichtig also es gibt nicht immer
wieder die gleichen leute die bei ihnen
aus schlagen denn dann würden die auch
hinter gitter kommt sondern das sind
immer wieder neuer
eines wiederholungstäter ist eine
wiederholungstäterin bekannt sind ist
tatsächlich so sind immer wieder neue
die dann ihre strafen christian
teilweise im jugend rechnung unterwegs
sind und dann kommen die nächsten das
ist vielleicht auch teil dieses drachen
games ist jeder auch spielen dass mich
immer wieder neu produziert durch andere
provozierten so vielleicht auch dinge
bewusst in kauf nimmt und deswegen ist
eine unendliche spirale der einzige
ausweg scheint tatsächlich zu sein und
das hat er auch die gemeinde man darf
nicht vergessen dieses haus kauft jetzt
die gemeinde wenn man die bilder sieht
also ich war noch nie das schaut jetzt
nicht so aus als würde man
durch das team hat jetzt da war sie
erworben hat sondern es schaut
vielleicht auch so einfach aus wird das
suchen alles um das irgendwie zu lösen
man sieht das problem ist ganz schwer
man kann jetzt nicht einfach entfernen
wie ist denn wie reagieren denn die
hater die dann verurteilt wäre zeigen
die so etwas wie reue
verstehen die dass das was sie da machen
wirklich nicht nur grenzwertig ist
sondern auch wirklich grenzen
überschreitet und blankes mobbing
wesentlich verstehen es nicht also wir
hatten in der hauptverhandlung ja zwei
der verurteilten hater als zeugen die
hatten bereits strafbefehle kassiert und
konnten dann also als zeugen zur
verfügung stehen weiß dass sich selbst
ja nicht mehr belastet haben und die
haben jetzt nicht von reue geplagt sandy
nicht aufgetreten sondern es waren zwei
medizinstudenten
die am weihnachtsmarkt sich vorher mut
angetrunken haben sich über die an die
antisemitischen und frauenfeindlichen
ausfälle des reinery unterhalten haben
nach mehreren kleinen und bier
mutmaßlich konstruktiv unterhalten haben
dann sind sie mit dem zug heraus
gefahren das haben die beschrieben und
haben als im zeugenstand immer wieder
betont ihren akt der zivilcourage
dienste darin sehen und was hat die
richterin da gemacht war ganz ehrlich
das darf man den ja auch nicht
durchgehend das ist selbstjustiz wir
hatten uns vorher inhalt an der stelle
eine art sehr massiven art und weise
nachgefasst steht im urteil dieser
passus der gewiss von schönreden die
rede also dass ich habe das noch selten
erlebt ist eine staatsanwältin die
richterin auf zeugen anfangs seien so
massiv dann auch nach losgegangen ist
vielleicht übertrieben so massiv
nachgefragt wird es kam deutlich zum
ausdruck dass man da überhaupt kein
verständnis hat der rechten hand hält
sich in der urteilsbegründung als in der
mündlichen grünen haben wir deutlich
emotionaler geäußert als das jetzt in
der papierform ist und hat da
tatsächlich eben auch gesprochen davon
gesprochen dass sie das eben alles als
menschenverachtend findet dass er kein
verständnis hat sogar eine vor rede
gehalten das macht sie normal nie aber
hier wird es immer was sagen und hat er
mit den worten dann geändert ich kann
mir das nicht gerne schlicht meine
arbeit sie am straftaten begangen und
ich kann da jetzt ein anderes gesetz das
sie anwenden und das alles bringt schon
zum ausdruck dass also von seiten der
richterin und das wahren der ganzen
verhandlung zu spüren null verständnis
für irgend einer form für diese hacker
szene warten ist ich tue mich ehrlich
gesagt ein schon wieder ein bisschen
schwer damit dass wir jetzt auch in
diesem gespräch eigentlich nicht mal
deutlich sagen
also wir sagen deutlich dass die hater
täter sind ich glaube da sind sich alle
einig die frage ist ja aber die auch
sascha lobo für sich sehr eindeutig
behandelt hat ist rainer w nur ein opfer
oder ist auch rainer w auch ein täter
das ist ja jetzt sozusagen die frage an
der sich alles entzündet hat wenn ich
glaube alle sind sich einig dass einer
wie ein opfer ist und zwar von
grauenvolle mobbing nicht nur
cybermobbing sondern auch vor ort ich
glaube jeder mensch kann auch
nachvollziehen dass man hochgeht aber er
hat eben ja auch seinen teil dazu
beigetragen und das nicht nur weil er
einmal diesen kolossalen fehler gemacht
hat seine adresse zu unseren nennen und
zu sagen dann kommt doch vorbei und ich
zeige es euch so zu sagen sondern weil
er ja auch immer weitermacht und das ist
ja auch das was im urteil steht dass es
das was die richterin ihm angeboten hat
bei dem versuch einer verständigung wäre
es denn nicht einfach sinnvoller das
ganze zu lassen und die spirale der
gewalt nicht immer weiter anzuheizen und
ich persönlich aus meiner sicht meiner
eigentlich dass dieser aspekt
gerechtfertigt ist und das ist so
einfach zu sagen rainer w ist ein opfer
das hier wies gemobbt wird schlicht
nicht ist denn das kind sind zwei
aspekte einmal hat er die geister die
ihn jetzt heimsuchen selbst gerufen als
er 2014 gesagt hat komm doch her und er
ruft sie jeden tag wieder oder zumindest
mit jedem internet video wieder oder wie
sieht das hier die runde ich bin bei
ihnen also ich bin auch der auffassung
es kann einem passieren in einem akte
entgleisung zu schreien kommt doch aber
letztlich wiederholt das ja also er
selbst immer wieder neue anlässe weil er
ja auch nicht möchte dass
aber entschuldigung trotzdem muss da
niemand anreisen das vielleicht auch
noch mal deutlich gesagt ja und das der
medizinstudenten anreisen und ob die
alkoholisiert sind oder nicht das finde
ich einfach noch mal skurril also
normalerweise man guckt so war und
schaltet doch ab
also was geht in diesen händlern vor
dass sie nicht nur dran bleiben sondern
auch noch hinfahren das eine hat mit dem
anderen nichts zu tun aus meiner sicht
doch wer also weil das die händler sich
strafbar verhalten sich völlig
unmenschlich verhalten und dass sich da
ein mob zusammengerottet das ist
überhaupt nicht die frage sondern die
frage ist inwiefern rainer w dazu etwas
beiträgt und das soll diesen moment
keiner weise es klingt mir es klingt mir
nur so ein bisschen zu zwangsläufig so
nach dem motto er sagt komm doch her
dann wurde darf man sich nicht wundern
dass sie kommen also ich wundere mich
darüber trotz dass das wollte ich nur
einmal deutlich sagen da ich jetzt noch
mal neu an
weil ich natürlich nicht die meinung
vertrete
wenn man einmal hat kommt doch dann ist
man auch selber schuld und dann ist es
auch gerechtfertigt also das so will ich
nicht verstanden birgt das siehst du
auch so also so will ich auch nicht
verstanden werden ich erinnern an einen
anderen fall der schon sehr viel länger
her ist falter reza das war als facebook
auf kam ein mädchen das irgendwie in
falschen haken gesetzt hat und hat
deutschland zu ihrer geburtstagsparty
eingeladen hat wenn sie sich zurück
erinnern ich glaube das war in hamburg
genau das ergebnis waren verwüstete des
elternhauses zur wüste der garten und
alles andere als eine schule
geburtstagsfeier ich würde jetzt aber
nicht sagen wollen dass es eine
parallele zwischen diesem mädchen und
dieser
sozusagen
da ist ja auch die cyberwelt
übergesprungen in die realität ich würde
da keine parallele zur eine riesen
ziehen wollen weil er und deshalb sagte
ich er wiederholt es ja ständig und er
generiert ja daraus auch für sich
sozusagen man dass da gekommen wird er
hat sich wie das eben sein
bewährungshelfer auch formuliert in
dieser opferrolle eingerichtet weil er
monetär aber auch emotional von dieser
aufmerksamkeit profitiert und die
eigenanteile damit bin ich bei florenz
erste zeile eigenanteil nicht diesen
eindruck hat man sehr stark wenn man
ihnen zuhört das sehe ich auch so er
betont immer sehr stark dass ein opfer
von mobbing ist und schon immer war dass
er schon in der schule gemobbt worden
ist und so und nimmt halt deshalb unter
diesem unter dieser die sims etwas sich
schulen in der opferrolle auch diesen
polizeilichen schutz mit einer
selbstverständlichkeit in anspruch die
einen schon so ein bisschen merkwürdig
aufstößt jedenfalls geht mir das so aber
dann wiederum ist das in der tat eine
selbstverständlichkeit ehrlich gesagt
also dass die polizei anrückt wenn sowas
passiert die polizei muss natürlich
anrücken wenn jemand in akuter gefahr
aber wenn jemand sich permanent selbst
in akute gefahr begibt finde ich kann
man durchaus mal nachfragen wie weit der
staat dann auch noch irgendwie vorwürfen
ausgesetzt werden kann wenn er nicht
immer und immer und immer wieder diese
provokation mit geht die polizei kommt
ja auch dass man einfach betonen und
dann wird eben doch immer wieder auch
wenn die massiv beleidigt das ist schon
ein punkt den ich nicht weglassen möchte
ich denke die diskussion zeigt ich bin
irgendwie bei ihnen allen einmal richtig
ab 50 war gut dass ich kann nicht
nachvollziehen warum man da hinfährt ich
weiß nicht wer da muss man vorher
betrunken sein oder was auch immer sie
habe keinerlei verständnis dafür und
wenn man hinfährt straftaten begeht
ordnungswidrigkeiten geht dann ist die
botschaft dann wird man auch bestraft
umgekehrt habe ich auch keine
verständigung ist dann wenn jemand
vielleicht ich kann es nicht
nachvollziehen vielleicht kann man sogar
verständnis empfinden aber trotzdem kann
jemand der massiv gemobbt wird auch
nicht straftaten begehen ist dafür nicht
und es muss bestrafen können und ich
glaube er hat das angebot zu einem sehr
prominenten mobbingopfer geschafft wir
haben sehr viele fälle von mobbing auch
immer mal wieder bei der justiz wo
tatsächlich am ende des auf wenn der
täter ist auf dem schulhof er wird so
lange die bücher tasche wird versteckt
und was auch immer man also kleine
nadelstiche und irgendwann raste zum
menschen mal aus und haut dann jemanden
eine reine und bleibt mit schlimmen
folgen so werden der landet bei uns wird
natürlich strafmildernd berücksichtigt
aber man darf überhaupt wird keine
straftat begehen denn punkt werde vorher
anzusetzen wie kann man verhindern dass
etwas passiert vielleicht kann man aus
diesen anden stück auch dinge lernen
sicher wären youtuber vielleicht 1000
dann bitte keine adressen preisgeben
wird eher klein aber auch andere
menschen mal unterstützt die
allerletzten dass jemand dem man
eigentlich ablehnt dann wieder
finanziell massiv fast 6000 euro
manchmal im monat ist ein erhebliches
geld ist die hater sozusagen die kasse
des nrw spielen also das ganze
persönliche kaum zu fassendes phänomen
das zeigt ja auch das interesse des
vorhanden ist ich sehe auch keine lösung
empfehlen um das zu sagen hat auch der
logos der seele geschrieben aber
weil er das problem globalisiert hat
aber letzten endes dass der rainer w nur
opfer ist das kann man nicht
unterschreiben erst strich tauchte und
das will sie auch verurteilt worden muss
verteilt werden ist ja auch ein
wichtiger hinweis dass das klassisch ist
für solche mobbing situationen da ist
einfach das strafrecht natürlich auch in
seinem engen korsett
gefangene also auch opfer die zu täter
werden in der größten verzweiflung
müssen sich der verantwortung stellen
und das wird dann auch berücksichtigt
aber das dilemma ist da und da kommen
wir wahrscheinlich auch nicht raus
nämlich an auskommen bekommt man nicht
aus weil man kann zu dem man eben nicht
er hat eine freundschaft überlegt was
das ist die idee freispruch noch mal
eine bewegung geben ich kann als
richterin richter nicht eine bewährung
geben wenn die voraussetzungen nicht
vorliegen und das ist glaube ich in dem
urteil sehr eingehend begründet warum
man das hier nicht so gesehen hat und
ich kann natürlich auch niemand
freisprechen wenn der oder die eine
straftat begangen hat das jetzt müssen
wir uns an recht und gesetz halten alles
andere wäre eine rechtsbeugung das kann
man glaube ich uns auch nicht verlangen
vielleicht jetzt wo wir doch zum schluss
kommt würde ich mich noch interessieren
was hat denn jetzt diese massive kritik
wieder an die der richterin an der stad
an werden die ja jetzt in der kolumne
geäußert wurde von sascha lobo was
wiederum hat die mit diesen personen
gemacht
wollen sie dazu was jahres vielleicht
zunächst einmal schlicht auf mich
beziehen ich habe das insofern unfair
gefunden als jemand nicht da war viele
dinge die die kollegen gesagt hat und
die ja genau das waren was in dem
artikel nicht kritisiert wurde dann auch
nicht erwähnt wurden das war für mich
persönlich sehr schwierig zumal wir
versucht haben den medien david platz zu
geben und das war noch kamen auch alle
reihen die reinkommen wollten haben ganz
bisschen aufgestockt gehabt also das war
so was was mich persönlich und der
pressearbeit getroffen hat das angebot
war da man konnte sich anschauen konnte
zuhören man hätte dann viele dinge
gehört die man kritisiert hat das nicht
gesagt worden sind also das war was für
mich persönlich ich weiß von der
kollegin mit der natürlich danach
ausgesprochen dass sie das persönlich
auch getroffen hat also von der
zuständigen richtiger weil sie einfach
die dinge ja in ihrer urteilsbegründung
er wirklich sehr eindeutigen ich habe
das ein noch nie so gehört dass man das
auch deutlich gesagt hat art und weise
angesprochen hat dass ich sehr wohl
täter und opfer erwähnt hat usw und die
dinge auch in ihrem schriftlichen urteil
das er damals noch gar nicht vorlagen
meine ich sehr eingehend also ein
amtsgerichtsurteil von 30 seiten das ist
eine seltenheit da muss ich sagen die
hat sich da wirklich mühe gegeben geht
eben auf die punkte alle ein und
versucht eigentlich der person finde ich
gerecht zu werden den taten gerecht
werden prüft sogar neben den 35 ist die
gewesen und folgen erwähnt er schon fast
ein bisschen wissenschaftlich die ganze
sache angepackt um ihm zu sagen ich will
wirklich auf alles ein geben dann wird
man doch sehr massiv persönlich
angegriffen und fehlen viele dinge ich
glaube das ist auch schwer
nachzuvollziehen lässt man das denn so
als mensch ich sage mal quasi in
richterrobe tatsächlich so nah an sich
heran obwohl man doch eigentlich weiß
ganz offensichtlich der war weder im
saal und sascha lobo auch kolumnist und
kein relikt gerichtsreporter noch hat er
sich offensichtlich mit meiner
urteilsbegründung auseinandergesetzt
lässt man das so menschlich an sich ran
also ich kann es nur von mir persönlich
sagen ja weil
da haben wir einfach das gefühl hat er
ein stück weit fairness nämlich die
fairness jemandem zuzuhören jemanden an
zu hören die man auch die chance zu
geben sich vielleicht zu äußern ich bin
jetzt auch gespeicherte zum beispiel
immer erreichbar ist und auch mal dinge
hätten nachfragen können und ich meine
die justiz muss mit kritik leben können
und es gibt auch wir machen auch fehler
und wir machen die geben manchmal auch
vielleicht so dass man es nicht in der
öffentlichkeit von anfang an
nachvollziehen kann man irgendwie das
sind die strafen entweder sind sie zu
niedriger das ist eine sehr schwierige
aufgabe die wir haben es gelingt uns
auch nicht immer zu transportieren warum
er was wir gemacht haben ist
dass man uns zuhört und das bei uns auch
dieses auditorin altera pars den schönen
lateinischen satz ich finde den hat auch
die justiz verdient
und es ist nicht vielleicht sogar so
dass die erwartungen die er häufig von
der öffentlichkeit gerade an
strafprozesse gestellt wird das
sozusagen jetzt im rahmen eines
strafprozesses der sich denkt notwendig
nur gegen einen angeklagten richten kann
eine komplette aufarbeitung eines
gesamten und ja auch hier sehr sehr
komplexen systems erfolgt diese
erwartung die kann man doch eigentlich
als strafrichterin oder strafrichter gar
nicht erfüllen wir haben es schon
angesprochen ich habe einen angeklagten
auf der auf der anklagebank sitzen ich
habe eine tat in dem fall viele taten
die besprochen werden müssen das heißt
eigentlich muss ich doch wissen als
strafrichterin auch dass sich diese
erwartungen der öffentlichkeit
strukturell gar nicht erfüllen kann oder
ich denke das ist tatsächlich ein
problem dass wir in vielen prozessen
haben wir können ja zunächst mal nur das
entscheiden oder strafrechtlichen strafe
der können nur wir das entscheiden was
überhaupt mal geliefert weil das
gegenstand der ist ich werde oft gefragt
warum bis jetzt nicht wegen dieser
geschichte nur verurteilt und sage ich
will das gar nicht in der anklage drin
stand nun natürlich ist es zunächst mal
schlicht die aufgabe eine angeklagte tat
aufzuklären die wahrheit zu ermitteln
war das kann sie so und wenn es so war
dann muss man eine angemessene strafe
finden und dafür gibt es regularien an
die man sich halten muss und da gibt es
auch nicht so viel spielraum natürlich
ist die strafzumessung
ermessensentscheidung das ist der ist
dass man sich sicherlich bewusst wenn
man so ein prozess geht es um so ein
komplexes geflecht über das wir jetzt
auch lange gesprochen haben sich auf
arbeiten nicht auf größen kann sondern
am schluss nur übrig bleiben war er
schuldig und wenn ja wie bestrafe ich
ihn letzten endes und trotzdem glaube
ich ist hier der versuch unternommen
worden das auch noch mit einer vorrede
und anderen eben diesen doch sehr
speziellen prozess gerecht zu werden und
dann glaube ich ist es schade wenn das
völlig unter den tisch gekehrt werden am
schluss nur das wort übrig bleibt noch
ein interessanter aspekt vielleicht zum
abschluss ich habe gelesen in
agenturmeldungen dass richterin und
staatsanwältin beide nicht namentlich
genannt werden wollten und ich habe
irgendwo gehört dass das wohl sogar für
journalistinnen und journalisten in dem
verfahren galt ist das zutreffend und
wenn ja warum also der name der
richterin wurde schon genannt und stand
ja auch außen drauf natürlich ist die
kollegen jetzt vor wenn sie in der
anonymität sage ich mal bleiben kann
weil das auch eine geschichte ist sieht
man auch die mit smoking eventuell nach
sich ziehen kann was ich absolut
bestätigen kann dass viele
journalistinnen und journalisten nicht
vor der kamera was machen wollten nur
ein stück substanz gedreht haben und das
ist muss ich sagen ist mir noch nicht
begegnet das eine optisch lassen über
die maske auf wir wissen doch jetzt hier
in einem raum entlüftung wir können das
mit abstand das ist nicht der grund
sondern ich möchte nicht dass man mein
gesicht in diesem zusammenhang in
irgendeiner form wieder erkennen kann
also das war ganz überwiegend so oder
überwiegend ist vielleicht nicht das
richtige wort aber alle die in
bildjournalismus unterwegs waren das
thematisiert zumindest gesagt mir
überlegen in der redaktion ob ich
gezeigt werde auf meinen namen
eingeblendet wird und so weiter und und
das fand ich schon sehr spannend und das
zeigt dass dieser fall tatsächlich für
alle besonders ist für die justiz
journalistin journalisten und
eigentlich für alle die daran beteiligt
sind frau löw sind sieht eine besonders
mutige kollege
das werde ich nicht sagen ich bin da
einfach der auffassung dass es unser job
also ich steh staunen da aber schon seit
vielen jahren weil mir das an dem
verfahren tatsächlich auch es erst
einmal passiert ist dass richter
staatsanwälte staatsanwälte in den
richterinnen der rechtsanwalt der
bewährungshelfer behördenmitarbeiter die
wollen alle nicht mitnahmen
und dass es auch noch auch in dem dorf
im übrigen will man nicht mit namen in
dieser in diesem phänomen genannt werden
dass sich das jetzt noch auf kollegen
von uns erstreckt erschreckt mich
und es geht ja weiter muss man hier
sagen im märz ist der berufungsprozess
also wir sind noch lange lange nicht am
ende dieses dieser tragödie muss man
wirklich so sagen und alle die beteiligt
sind die dahin pilgern sollten sich das
sehr sehr genau fragen ich würde sagen
wir haben den fall jetzt hinreichend
besprochen ich danke wirklich sehr
erweitern frau löw dass sie sich die
zeit genommen haben hier so kurz vor
weihnachten ja wirklich sehr ausführlich
über diesen fall zu gehen ich fand es
wirklich unglaublich erhellend fand wir
haben viele dinge besprochen die glaube
ich so vielleicht auch viel in unserer
hörerinnen und hörer nicht bekannt war
herzlichen dank dafür
ja und das war sozusagen jetzt die
letzte folge des faz einspruch podcast
in diesem jahr im jahr 2021 es war kein
sehr weihnachtliches thema aber das
weihnachtsfest war vielleicht auch etwas
worüber man ja mal nachdenken kann wir
hören uns wieder und zwar nach einer
kleineren
winterpause am 12 januar geht's wieder
weiter und dann werden wir eine menge
zusammenfegen an rechtlichen themen wie
sie es gewöhnt sind und bis dahin sagen
wir frohe weihnachten und guten rutsch
[Musik]